Today for the experts
in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with
Dr Naomi Eisenberger, um,
on the nature of social pain.
So Dr Eisenberger received her phd
from Ucla and is currently an associate
professor of psychology still at Ucla
and the co director of the social
cognitive neuroscience laboratory.
Her work focuses on understanding
social pain as well as social pleasure.
This includes the neural basis of
social rejection, social connection,
as well as social support and health.
She's published widely in top tier
journals including science, social,
cognitive aspect of neuroscience,
and the proceedings for the National
Academy of Sciences. Dr Eisenberger,
his work has been recognized by numerous
awards, including a Narsad award.
Janet Taylor Spence award from the
association for Psychological Science,
the sage young scholars award,
and the Herbert Wiener early career
award from the American psychosomatic
society.
So I now turn with great pleasure to our
experts and emotion interview together
with Dr Naomi Eisenberger.
So welcome Naomi. Thanks for speaking
today. Thank you for having me.
What I wanted to start out with is just
asking you a little bit about what first
got you interested in emotion.
Um,
I don't know that there
was any one incident.
I think I've always been really interested
in psychological experience and very
sort of attuned to what's going on in
my mind and what's going on in my body.
And emotion is one of those things that
sort of captures your attention in ways
that other experiences don't
necessarily capture it. So, you know,
you notice that all of a sudden your
body feels different in your foundations
are different and what you're
thinking about is different. Um,
and I think that's just sort of what,
what got me interested in emotion.
Excellent.
Well I wanted to ask you about some of
your work in this field because you've
really, you know, pioneer and you know,
work on the neural basis of
things really relevant to emotion,
like social rejection, showing
that social pain can actually hurt.
And so I wondered if you could say
a little bit about your work here,
talking about how social pain may
actually share similar brain mechanisms to
physical pain.
Yeah.
So I been interested in rejection for
awhile just because rejection is one of
those kinds of experiences that can, you
know, change your emotions in major ways.
You know,
people,
all of a sudden when they're giving a
speech and they know that they can be
evaluated,
that they could be rejected and all of a
sudden you've had your heart racing and
your mouth gets dry.
Um,
people go to great lengths to
avoid getting rejected. Um,
so we do all these things to try to
prevent rejection in our own lives.
And I was just sort of curious, how
does the brain process rejection? Um,
and so we brought people in to the FMRI
scanner and we set up this game that kip
Williams has used before called cyberball.
And essentially what happens here is
people play this online virtual ball
tossing game well with what they think
are two other individuals and happens is
they're playing the ball together and
that at a certain point in time, um,
the two players who are
actually controlled by a
computer stop throwing the ball
to the subject, the subject
essentially a socially excluded. Um,
and so here we could look at what's
going on in the brain during that moment
when individuals are
feeling socially excluded,
when they're experiencing
social exclusion. Um,
and when we were running this study,
got back the data and I
was actually analyzing it,
I was sitting next to a fellow graduate
student who was analyzing a study on
physical pain and this was a study like
in irritable bowel syndrome patients.
So these were serious chronic
pain patients. We were
sitting next to each other.
We each had our data up
on our computer screens.
And at some point we noticed
just how similar our data looked.
I was looking at a study
on social rejection.
She was looking at a
study on chronic pain,
manipulated pain experience.
And at some point you sort of,
it got hard to tell which
study you were looking at.
And so based off that we thought,
you know,
it sort of looks like social rejection
is activating some of these same neural
regions that are implicated
in physical pain processing.
And in some ways it makes sense when you
think about this from an evolutionary
perspective,
given how important social
connection is for human survival.
And for more broadly speaking,
Mammalian survival. Um,
it's possible that the system that makes
sure that we stay socially connected
me, I've actually piggyback right
on top of the physical pain system.
So kind of borrowing that pain signal,
not only to alert us when our bodies
are in danger of being harmed,
but when our social relationships or
in danger of being harmed as well.
Such fascinating work. And it makes me
wonder, I know you've done some work here,
you know, to what extent, you know,
can we think about using interventions
then that are focused on alleviating
physical pain to remedy sort
of everyday social pain?
Um, so we've looked at that a little
bit. So based on this physical, social,
social pain overlap,
we've been very interested in whether
altering one kind of experience can alter
the other in a similar way. Um, and
we've been able to show that, you know,
maybe some surprising things that things
like a regular over the counter pain
killers like Tylenol.
Not only can reduce physical pain,
but it seems to be capable of
reducing social pain as well.
And I'm not suggesting people go
ahead and take a bunch of time.
There are other ways,
if you think about similarities
between physical and social pain,
there are other things
that can ameliorate both.
So any kind of activity that
increases opioid processing.
So opioids are also potent
painkillers in there, you know,
we have them within our bodies. And so
any activity like for example, exercise,
which increases the release of opioids,
um,
may have not only physical pain,
reducing effects, social pain,
reducing effects as well.
So interesting. I mean, and
I'm also thinking, you know,
of this domain of work
that's just so fascinating,
changed the way of what we think of,
you know, what social pain really is.
You've also been conducting work looking
at I guess the lighter side of social
connection as well by exploring
social connection and social pleasure.
And I wondered if you could tell us a
little bit about what we know about the
neurocircuitry here that may underlie
these ceilings of social warmth.
Yeah.
So we've sort of more recently tried to
switch our focus a little to focus on
some of them are positive
aspects of social relationships.
And we've done this in a
number of different ways. Um,
you mentioned social warms.
So in the same way that we've been looking
at what are sort of the neural bases
of social pain,
what are the sort of more basic neural
systems that may have been co opted to
support socially painful experiences.
We've also been trying to do the
same thing on the positive side.
So what are the more basic neural systems
that may have been co opted to support
those feelings of social connection?
Um,
and so one of the experiences that
we've looked at, his social warmth,
these are sort of the warm feelings
that we have when we feel bonded and
connected with others.
Um,
and we've been cheerious and interested
in whether these experiences rely on
temperature regulation mechanism.
So a lot of times we'll say things like,
um, uh, you know,
I have a warm feeling towards that
person or I've felt warm hearted.
So we use these,
um,
temperature related words to describe
feelings of social closeness.
Um, so in a recent study in,
this isn't published yet,
but in a recent study we
tried to manipulate and
experience of social warmth and
manipulate and experience of physical
warms and look to see if we're getting
overlapping or activity and regions
that typically process temperature and
physical warmth. Um, so
in the social warms task,
essentially we bring in subjects and
ahead of time we contact their friends and
family members and we have
them provide us with, um,
sort of loving email
messages. Um, so it's,
these are actually very touching.
They were things like, you know,
I couldn't live my life without you in it.
These were real messages from
their family and friends. Um,
so they did one task where
they were reviewing these
messages for the first time
and then they did another task where they
were just sort of holding on to a warm
pack, um, when they were in the scanner.
And this was compared to a control
condition when they were holding onto a
squeeze ball.
Um,
and so essentially what we
found was overlapping neural
activity in two regions.
Um,
the mid insula and the ventral striatum
regions that in prior studies have been
shown to be involved in
processing physical warmth. Um,
so we see that there may be some, and
you know, this is a beginning study,
but there may be some kind of overlap,
um,
between the neural mechanisms that are
involved in processing temperature and in
processing social warmth than some other
behavioral studies have shown this as
well.
So if you like work by John Barge,
if you hold on to a warm cup of coffee,
perceive other people as warmer.
Um, and this is sort of a neural
investigation of some of those overlapping
mechanisms.
So, interesting. I mean,
what do you think, you know,
are going to be some of the most
important advances in this field of social
warmth as it moves forward? I mean, your,
your findings that you're talking about
that you're currently working on right
now are some of them,
but do you think there's other important
directions that we want to move forward
and to really understand what social
warmth is? Especially at the neural level.
Um, yeah, I mean I don't know
exactly where this will go,
but there's so many different kinds of
experiences that can make people feel
socially connected. You know,
we've looked at social warmth,
we've also looked at experiences where
people are feeling understood by others,
which seems to tap into some of these
same reward related neural regions.
And so I think going forward what would
be nice and what I'm ultimately looking
for is some kind of larger theoretical
framework for understanding all of these
different types of experiences
of social connection.
How do we organize them?
Um,
are they sub divided in some kind of
meaningful way? So that's at this point,
what I wanted to some kind of
larger theoretical structure
for understanding all
of these smaller types of
positive social experiences.
And speaking of this domain work,
I mean finally you've also
done some really important
work looking at questions,
aim to understanding the role that
social support plays, you know,
in our physical health.
And I wonder what you think we know
right now about this link between social
support and health.
Yeah. So this is probably actually the
question that first got me interested in
psychology in the first place.
Um,
I think I was an Undergrad at the time
and learned about the strong link between
social support and health and really,
you know, for the past 30 or so years,
this has been one of the strongest
findings within the field of health
psychology and social epidemiology.
The people who have fewer social ties
are at a greater risk for morbidity and
mortality and the risk factor is
on par with things like smoking.
So smoking is a risk factor for health
on par with not having social ties.
And so I've always been curious on why,
why does that relationship exists?
What are the mechanisms that explain that
link between social support and health?
Um, and so we've been doing a
little bit of work on this domain,
sort of starting from the top,
starting to try to understand what are
the neural mechanisms that underlie
experiences of social support.
And we focus both on what's going on
when people are receiving social support
from others as well as what's going on,
when people are getting
social support to others. Um,
and I think probably, oh, sorry,
I'm skipping to your next question.
No, go ahead. What have you found
most interesting things because it seems
kind of counterintuitive comes from
some of the work that we've been
doing on support giving. Um,
so I think when people
think about social support,
they sort of assume that all of that
psychological benefits or all the health
benefits come from all the stuff
that we get from other people,
all the support that they give us.
Um,
and we've been exploring whether some of
the benefits also come from the support
that we give to others.
So we've looked,
we've been looking neurally at what's
going on when people are engaged in giving
support to a significant other.
So in this particular study,
we bring in couples,
we scan the females as they
provide support to their
partners or their partners
stand right outside the scanner.
And on some trials their
partner gets electric shock, um,
while the female holds his arm as
he goes through this experience.
And what we find in these studies is
greater activity in reward related regions
that seem to be implicated in maternal
care giving behavior in animals.
And what's interesting is there seems
to be this hint that when people are
engaged in support giving,
not only does it activate
these reward related regions,
but it seems to relate to less activity
in certain regions that are often
associated with processing threats
of regions like the Amygdala.
And so we think that,
you know,
one possibility is that the active support
giving is actually threat reducing in
some kind of way,
at least physiologically speaking.
And we're currently looking at more into
this or running a study where people
are randomly assigned to either provide
support or go through a controlled task
before they go through their
own stressful experience.
And this particular situation,
people who are just engaged in support
giving actually seem to be less
physiologically responsive.
They show less of an increase in heart
rate and blood pressure in response to
that later stress task. Um, so there,
there may be sort of more
benefits to support giving,
um, then just for the person
receiving the support.
So where do you see the future of this
field headed and from your perspective?
Um, I don't know. I will
be excited to find out.
I guess I feel like emotion research
is probably still in the early stages.
When I teach my course and emotion,
which is typically taught as a graduate
course, I probably spend, you know,
the first three classes,
um,
either talking about
just what is an emotion.
Just sort of going over the definition,
going over people's different
approaches to understanding it. Um,
so even the fact that we don't sort of
have an agreed upon definition yet to me
suggests that we're in
the very early stages.
So I don't know what the future holds,
but I will be excited to see as there's
more and more research coming in.
And what advice do you typically give
to students then who come to you asking
about, should I embark in this
field of emotion? You know,
how should I be spending my time,
or what should I be doing? Well,
I of course think emotion is one of the
most interesting topics in the world.
So anyone who's coming to me interested,
I would suggest definitely
go down that line.
But I guess I would recommend
a reading as much as you can,
reading from lots of
different perspectives, um,
but also sort of keeping in mind your
own experience and like d and does your
own experience jive with these
different theoretical perspectives?
I love that.
So reading widely and really connecting
your own experience to the science that
you're reading in front of your
eyes. [inaudible] great. Yeah. Well,
thank you so much for speaking today,
Naomi.
It was wonderful to hear your thoughts
and have this opportunity to thank you so
much.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Naomi Eisenberger
from the University of California,
Los Angeles. Thank you so much.